hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play lone
survivor okay I'm gonna see if I can get
anything on the radio again the director
I don't got nothing special maybe it's
not worth visiting right now it's
probably a good assumption to make okay
if I remember how to play cuz it has
been a while I need to go downstairs and
from what you guys have told me I need
to not kill as many people as possible I
need to definitely not go on a crazy
murdering spree and destroy every one of
these bastards that I see that would be
detrimental to my progress ya hear him I
know there's okay so he's standing right
in front of that doorway that seems to
be filled with a bunch of those things I
don't recall what was in here Harmon 105
Hartman 105 was all blocked up besides
oh hang on I didn't get this bottle of
milk and stuff right here ground
espresso powder hey I'm gonna be very
conservative about my flashlight here Oh
as opposed to this guy here I'm still
not entirely sure how I'm supposed to
get around him cuz I would have thought
that this would have been a hidey hole
right here but apparently not uh I don't
know I don't know what I'm supposed to
do I'm gonna run away like a screaming
little babby and then go over to the
other side while I run into the same
exact frickin problem Oh
what was in here oh he's just standing
in the doorway still creepily okay so
there was a bunch of meat here is there
any way that I could like umm cause this
meat to I don't know be better I'm not
sure hang on let me check my how do I
even get into my oh there we go
I don't recall anymore got plenty of
bullets but you guys said that I
probably shouldn't do anything about
that
ah can't open their scissors bucket
maybe I could somehow use maybe I could
somehow use
I don't know I'm kind of reaching here
no stop looking at a Melbourne over here
last light handgun cap plus bucket
schizos can't open her saucepan go I
hear something else in the background
there and why would I need to hide here
where in the world what I need to hide
here there's gotta be something with
that meat and that guy oh wait a minute
no no no no no no I have it wait no no
no no no no no hang on wait a second I'm
getting a brain wave getting a brain
wave I put the meat oh he's just
standing right there he doesn't do
nothing but okay so if I put the meat
wait till it goes away and then I place
the rotting meat right here highway ah
Giggy Giggy Oh Giggy I gotta do it again
right here place the rotting meat here
and cutting this one awfully close to
the chest you don't see anything
hide okay I don't know what I'm hiding
from now but the situation has gotten
much more dire okay oh no no good
oh no about of me I never thought that'd
be a problem that I'd be shouting to the
heavens I'm out of meat forgot to
restock I'm so boned oh god damn it oh
god damn it how am I gonna get back I
can't get back oh maybe I could place
some not rotting meat I don't know what
do I have oh I don't know crap the only
thing I have is now I can't place
anything down I might just have to kill
this one ah
the alternative is going back and
getting hit or maybe I can go forward
and get hit oh god there's two of them
it's no boat
I'm so bummed I'm so bummed I don't want
to do it I don't know what to do I'm
trapped
oh [ __ ] it you know what we're gonna run
through don't run through what we're
gonna have to do ah I can't run through
ah I can't run through him
oh god I gotta kill him
come on show your dad back up
no real oh now run hun you dick
run you dick oh that was probably bad I
was a poor choice on my part they seemed
to be talking about a victim of an
accident apparently the unnamed victim
died in a bomb blast the victim was a
civilian in some war no idea which war
he's talking about wars are long since
over now it's just survival you say so
man yeah what is this what what where am
I
how did I get back here oh there's
something back here on the map you got a
second I've always hated the alleys
round back since before I can remember
I don't really want to go down here too
bad we're going get some stuff that what
my flashlights gone all wrong you mean
gone all wide hey what's going on here
whoa where do you come from
what's wrong with your face man did I
appear from nowhere I'm not sure to be
honest I don't know what you're saying
and I don't really like it either okay I
don't have much to say to you until we
meet for the third time goodbye
what who is that guy I know but he left
something close that all about canis
Dodi pop it's empty but there's
something rattling in it get the fire
door key all right son like what can't
see the dirt the batteries and those are
my last batteries and gun ammo man I
don't think I can kill a single other
thing if I want to get that ending that
you guys were talking about instant
coffee squid on us
dick something else Locke's broke and
can't open it I guess that's for the
best
shutting this down all right I'm not
doing so good
well they still have places that I can
go more specifically off to the left
there
might as well be worth a check before I
clock out here what feel close to
collapsing okay maybe I should go no
don't go in there you dick maybe I
should go back home for a second look
deeply into it I'm doing all right
except for all these bite wounds and
infections from these zombies I need to
eat something I'll just beat these
squids on a stick I'm not so sure about
this one you did fill me up though
that's good enough I guess sleepy sleepy
sleepy I'll have a snooze off you go
then
day seven that definitely helped good
glad to hear anything on the radio I'll
check out the director I don't got
nothing special fine
all right looking back in the mirror to
get back to where I were swamp all right
going outside and for the lift oh come
on oh wait no I'm not outside yet that's
right that's right I'm dumb I'm dumb hmm
lick lick fire dorky pissed off God
those freaker's are just so weird where
does this lead that looks slightly
disconcerting
he's the fire does he can get rid of the
key now he'll be no use oh boy it is
pitch black oh god pitch blackness oh
god there's a hole here can't hide there
not now kiss up
Oh what thing Oh golly
the monsters it's like damn it's like
damn good god I don't even see where the
guy is is right there cap [ __ ] dammit
all right I'm out I'm out I'm not doing
this anymore
goo that goo that go in here yeah the
front door is blocked but maybe there's
a way to get rid of that monster maybe I
should take another look around huh ah
wait a minute there was an X here that
wasn't exactly okay no that was just the
door is a hidey hole right here what I
need to do I forgot I have more rotting
meat in my fridge I need to go stock up
again
Oh time to use the magical window mirror
portal perfectly normal
I'm not crazy you're all crazy for
thinking I'm crazy
using the advocates okay back into the
kitchen we go see look at fridge stock
up a more rotting meat look I really
wish I didn't have to kill those guys I
mean I I didn't have any other choice it
would cuz I couldn't run past them
therefore I would have had a shot to go
back or shoot to go forward really no
choice okay so what I need to do is I
need to go the other way around and I
need to place the meat for the hidey
hole on the other side I can get by
these bastards and then the giant
[ __ ] there was a hiding point I do
all right here place the rotting meat
okay hide quickly hide they're really
making me cut it real close with this
hidey hole
Oh screw you wait is that a second what
I hear do I hear a second one
Hey exit what are you doing huh what did
you do I don't even know what just
happened what's going on oh oh oh oh no
I'm trapped
oh no oh no oh you bastards oh you
bastards there's something big behind
this door something I've not seen before
I can't go through this way well what am
I supposed to do then I'm trapped
between two dudes okay I think I walked
in with the light on ergo I oh oh oh
it's so big okay out of action and my
work if the emergency generator was
running how do I get to Oh
generator in the basement find a way to
the stairs somehow hey oh I'm not
getting any closer to that thing
probably good good kid thing alright so
oh I think I know what I have to do now
I was hoping to avoid going to the
basement crazy the hell out okay where's
that guy on the right hidey-hole where
is he I don't see him
it's pitch black oh he's there I know he
is aware
where is it I barely barely see my
outline oh maybe he's gone he's gone Oh
aha Oh down to the basement we go so
that's huge creature in the lobby maybe
I can get it into the elevator I can get
that working against somehow I know it
goes down to the basement anyway does it
Oh does it really theater
Gabby Reece I've been very careful about
my conservation I think I've killed
about I think I've killed about four
things I believe anyway wait I don't
have a map here need to get a map oh yes
whoa what's the shaking
oh I hear things to my left am i right
this game has been very good about doing
the sound locations they're light on
forcing no distress flare
what happens if I'll use it on a monster
oh no no I don't particularly want to
find out oh good a mirror anything else
in here
dad squid on a stick great go back home
for a bit I think I need to sleep anyway
I could use a bath but I could use a but
bath yes you see if I can can I cook
this threads good on a stick no I don't
think though I think dried squid on a
stick is just eating I've actually eaten
dried squid it's it's not horrible
fruit salad cheese crackers I'm actually
running out of food food Oh got plenty
of ammo but I don't want to use the ammo
a rotting meat I'm definitely not gonna
eat that and you guys told me that I
might need to eat take a pill
sometime but just not right now I must
sleep I'm gonna eat a dried squid on a
stick and then sleep no no no no no no
no no not now eat the squid first yes
bless
they'd fill me up though alright sleep
now have a little snooze and go on your
merry way you needed that I know you did
buddy that's why I'm here to support you
all the way I've got your back and I
know it's best ever I like how this room
is filled with blood is definitely a
good sign oh crap okay I hear footsteps
to the left but okay I heard that oh it
is dark here what what what was that I
got a map got a map there's something
marked over there
good the room already marked here - wait
am I in the hallway when they get in the
hallway no idea why though maybe maybe
maybe not
I don't know either man god I gotta
remember to turn off my flashlight like
go into please okay that guy's got us
something but I don't see a way around
and I'm not gonna show them that's damn
sure oh it is what is that there's a
hole ahead oh it's gas uh damn is gear
oh I nearly fell down there oh oh that
will you whoa if I had been going around
the darkness I would have fallen down
it's all add okay so don't do that don't
do that what did I go ah God what the
hell
Jesus don't scare me like that live
laugh and flopper damn I got a map Jesus
okay so that Way's blocked off and I
guess that might be the big thing that's
shaking the ceiling there
okay so there's something off to the
left definitely
was that uh-huh-huh
oh boy there it is okay
oh man this is amazed this one is
actually a maze-like place so I go down
this way down this hall here up a little
left block from the other side okay nope
nope nope nope no I need to turn off my
light but it spits [ __ ] black
there's one end then nothing oh come on
what am I supposed to do what was that
on the floor
that's awesome beyond the is that I see
something down there something's
crawling around the floor
maybe there's a hidey hole somewhere I
can't see anything I can't see anything
at all
real close II okay there's got to be a
way to go to the left here that I could
go around it I just don't know what yeah
sometimes our stopping I don't see I
don't see I don't see how yeah
what is this hey that's the door ah I
see you barely in the I know you guys
can't see anything but I got to walk
around in pitch blackness what do I do
Oh was that ah no wait no there was a
thingy there there was a thingy there if
he just moves just enough I can get to
the thingy mud
oh no no no oh whoa what it what gamma
Oh will that melts much better there's a
door there oh god I'm so close I know I
can get in there I can get in there I
know I can
I just got he's just gotta move move
your ass
what were your ass just a little more
aah like I've got burned
Oh what did it say ah yeah you smacking
me in the balls repeatedly repeatedly
Maggie me I can't get in there
maybe if I don't kill him I could shoot
him just enough to back him up back up
no back up back up back up back back up
oh god damn that didn't work at all
punch oh god no I'm dead vines good
thing I saved recently [ __ ] nutters
not that recently though god dammit god
dammit oh I love this music though
music's awesome okay so I fudge that up
real bad I don't know what I'm supposed
to do I there's got to be something I'm
missing but I don't know what I'll
figure it out in the next episodes oh
thank you all so much for watching click
the interface more videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
ah here is me
look for chomping the heads up
only all they do
Oh master
once again
super mega